foreign foreign
foreign
foreign
oh my God that's been
it's been a crazy ride but home delay
we're still here
bro it to me this is my first time
seeing you since we last spoke because
we we talk on the phone here and there
you know yeah there hasn't been a video
call so just seeing you in the beard bro
I'm sure people in the live chat are
gonna agree you look so different bro I
love them about it yeah bro I was and I
noticed the other day I was I was on
your on the video and I looked at myself
and I was like I look like a little kid
[Laughter]
a lot of a lot of the brothers and
sisters now that are tuning in you know
they're not OG they won t3m family
members so they have no idea who this
beautiful brother is they don't know
about your story so in a nutshell do you
want to quickly go over your revert
story how you came into Islam a little
bit about your past and upbringing just
for some of the new viewers
yeah of course well my name is Zach um
now now known as ali um alhamdulillah
you know I grew up in California
Southern California and I was a
Christian I grew up as a Christian you
know but I was asking myself like was
that the real was that was there any
truth in it because I really didn't feel
anything that was that was correct you
know especially regarding things that
happened in our life that broke away our
family you know and um
it made me question if God existed
because of of all the the cruelty in in
the human being you know in seeing my
family seeing my family broken apart
um at the other day I decided to come
back to Mexico because I thought that I
was going to be able to make a new life
you know
I came down here and I noticed that it
wasn't what I what I had expected it was
uh a cruel Awakening you know it's like
they they give me that cold bath to wake
up that it was this was the real world
you know
but being over here I would see a lot of
different religions from like uh Jehovah
Witness uh Witchcraft and all that and
and I would see how they would how they
would use that in violence you know and
I would question myself like I don't
consider myself to be a an evil person
but I I think that there should be
always be wrong my brother
no can you trim a little bit of beard
and send it over so I can patch up mine
I got you bro I got you say hey I'll
donate it to the the save the brothers
Foundation
donation bro for the save the brothers
Foundation I got you Habibi
nah that's good it's good you know and
um growing up by myself down here in
Mexico it was hard you know and I have
in my my dad or my mom not having nobody
around that could actually like you know
give me good advice ended up hanging
around with the wrong crowd you know um
and seeing people that I love go away
that pushed me in into the insane world
of the cartels you know
I ended up getting caught get getting
caught got sent to prison
um I was facing a murder charges they
were trying to give me 30 to 30 to life
30 years left um
I never thought I was gonna get out you
know I was like I ain't gonna get out
I'm gonna stay here but I'll make sure
that I they take advantage of what uh
what I came here to do in order I came
here to learn and it was something funny
that I would like I tell my wife and I
tell a lot of people like I was seeking
knowledge you know because I would I
would study military tactics I would
have my I would have my life discipline
regarding my body you know taking care
of my body practicing Sports
I didn't feel like I was I was I didn't
feel like I was going to war just
because I felt Brave and I was gonna
kill myself at the end you know I felt
like I had intelligence I had I had
something to demonstrate when I went in
there I went in there trying to look for
for knowledge you know at the end of the
day I went in there trying to look for
knowledge and and I would see how how
power and money would corrupt and how
they would oppress the the general
population you know it got to the point
where I uh being from a good spot where
I where I was getting to almost losing
my life inside of prison
um it got to me to make a there was a
little party going on there and I got
transferred to a bigger a bigger uh a
bare State Prison at the end of the day
I ended up in maximum security got to
see more of of what the human being is
like under stress you know under under
that that
under that that blindfold of of those
things that don't want us to to take the
right path you know I I I thought it was
I wasn't blindfold but I was blindfold
because I was I was falling into their
their ways and and I was going to end up
how they how they wanted me to end up
um being in there and not thinking I was
gonna make it out alive uh three years I
spent three years in prison uh the third
year when I I got released and they told
me that I was uh I would say I was uh
how do you guys say um addicted from
from any any charges I was proven
innocent and I got the the green light
to go out I came out and I didn't I
didn't say oh I'm gonna start my life
being a good person no I said now that I
have the knowledge I'm gonna do what I
have to do you know that that I thought
um
being involved in this environment and
seeing how easily life was taken away it
was like it started making me think you
know I know I'm not afraid of dying but
what's gonna happen after death you know
that's all that's always been my my
question like regarding any religion
nobody can tell you that you're gonna
die at the end of the day you know
that's the only thing that's sure that's
the only thing that we have to be
reminding of ourselves that we're that
we're this this body is going to fade
away
and
getting exposed to that and being under
that stress of of every day waking up
and thinking that this could be your
last day made me start questioning
myself you know you say you say you have
knowledge you say you're not you're not
one of them you're not one of the those
those cheap-minded people you're you
have them you have them
you have a mind because in in prison I
learned how to be humble you know it
humbled me and it made me see things a
lot different from when I was outside of
prison you know and I felt it wasn't it
wasn't no there it was no time lost
because at the end of the day
alhamdulillah those characters that I
learned in there and that I suffered in
there to learn were the ones that kept
me alive and kept me like
kept me growing as a person because I
wasn't I I always knew I wasn't an evil
person and I wasn't gonna give my life
to to these people you know at the end
of the day I wasn't going to give my
life to to those entities that wanted to
to drag me to the to the bottom you know
where there was no there was not going
to be a chance to say that you were
gonna do something right about your life
and it made me think about like um
where we came from like I would be up in
the mountains up in the ranges and and I
would see everything you know and it
would look beautiful bro and and it
would look like just like it would make
you Ponder of of who created this who
put this here there has to be an
explanation of why we're here you know
why is it that that
that we're born into this into this
world
um
and at that point I was like you know
what I'm I'm gonna I dropped everything
and I moved away
um I found a depression uh having to try
to adapt myself to a normal life you
know because everything in my world was
about respect you know if you respect me
we'll respect you if you disrespect me
if we're gonna We're not gonna take it
as a small offense and um
getting involved with with with the
society Society tends to lose those
values you know of being humble of of
having respect for others they find it
easier to disrespect to disrespect you
and I started battling with myself in
the way that I knew I was alone
I had spent 15 years of my life without
seeing my family without seeing my mom
my brothers my sisters
um
it led me to the point where I wanted to
take my life you know because I I knew
that I hadn't been any benefit for
nobody you know I hadn't I hadn't lived
a good life I had done I had done a lot
of harm
and I got to that point where I was
looking where to hang myself bro it got
really scary Annoying it gets really
scary for for those for those men that
have gone to that point where you you're
trying to like
tell yourself why are you still here you
know if you know that you you've heard a
lot of people you've you've done a lot
of damage
hang yourself you know because in prison
I saw that when you wanted to die you
could die like you don't have to hang
yourself from from a really big from a
really big spot you can hang yourself
just sitting on your way you know and
it's crazy bro to see people go away
like that like like that that have that
courage to take away their lives
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
do it you know but something told me
like so you were out there and
you you were out there with that
mentality that you were gonna die as a
warrior you know you that you weren't
gonna give up to come here and hang
yourself like a coward because you don't
know what's real because you don't know
what what's expecting for your life
I had to sit down and and
this is the most beautiful part of what
I always like remember you know that
I didn't
say anything to anybody you know I
didn't say Jesus I didn't say Jehovah I
didn't say anything bro coming from a
Christian a Christian background I
didn't say anything because I didn't I
just asked you know if you if you are
seeing me and if you if you're real and
there's a purpose in my life guide me to
something that is truthful that is right
that is that gives me that that feeling
that I'm I'm on the straight path
not knowing that it the next day you
know I would see khabib fight and like
because I was into MMA that I guess that
was the only thing that was keeping me
alive
um I started I started investing about
Islam you know and I fell in love with
it straight away because they're they're
perfect examples of a real Warrior is
you know
but it's crazy bro how many lights is it
was a blessing to actually
no
and like understand that that when I was
going to the corona when I was reading
that when you ask you know when you
really ask from the bottom of your heart
that there's nothing there that's that's
nothing that is is like how can I say
this when you ask without any benefit
from you know usually you're asking
because you have nothing else in in
that's gonna save you from from from
what you're living in and you ask truly
you don't you don't even have to say his
name he'll guide you you know he'll
guide you because
I was in the point of my life where I
was gonna hang myself bro come on you
know to to that to that extreme for a
person like me that's been 15 years by
by himself not having family living
going in and out of prison bro it's like
foreign
impacted me bro like even when I when I
speak in Spanish to the people that
asked me about it and to the homeboys
that I have in prison
like I have no I'm not ashamed of crying
bro I'm not ashamed of shedding tears
and then they tell me he's like no we
believe you wrong because you you've
been in our shoes
and you know what's up you know you know
you know the pain of of having nothing
and I tell my I tell a lot of people
that are close to me I tell them like
value what you have you know value your
family value your parents sometimes we
we take that for the least and we're
always fighting we're always
disrespecting and I and I tell them I
value it because it's it's it's it's
really sad to see how people have their
families people have their parents
people have their brothers and they
rather fight with them bro they rather
disrespect them not knowing that in
reality it hurts to be without your
friend Libra it really hurts and and you
can you you you you
being by yourself as a human being bro
you you will go
you'll get depressed bro because the
human being is not made to be by itself
you know
bro we're we're still strong here you
know and that's how I ended up here in
Islam and in the path that I'm in
alhamdulillah my brother
yeah bro and and since then a lot of
things a lot of brothers are wondering
what's changed bro what's the update
since you since the last stream a year
ago since the last stream
um
you know like it
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah well that's the greatest
um
we've suffered two kidnap attempts and
we lost I lost one of my sons my brother
and it was just a reminder you know that
from a while we come into Allah we'll
head back and we we cannot be distracted
with the with what we see daily you know
with our surroundings in this world that
that we live in because this world that
we live in is full of just distractions
my brother there's no reminders of of
that we are here today we might not be
here tomorrow you know
so
um it was like a I needed
I don't see it like um
a lot of people see like pain you know
but but
uh what everything that happens in our
lives my brother is from Allah
and we can make it occur so we can make
it a blessing you know and and I think
think to myself I was like alhamdulillah
my son will not be will not have to
taste Dunya no will not have to come to
this world to suffer because at the end
of the day that's what we come to do bro
there's a lot of pain in this world and
we think sometimes we live protected or
we live in a little bubble where where
we don't we don't wake up to reality you
know at the end of the day we are here
and tomorrow we're not
alhamdulillah brother where everything's
everything's good alhamdulillah
Grant your son Jonah and allow you to be
reunited on journal with him I mean
it's tough man and and just even going
through it bro a lot of people haven't
experienced grief you know and sometimes
we get desensitized to a lot of these
emotions because they're so new to us
but when when they happen every time bro
it's it's sometimes it's as if it's it's
the first time that we feel felt these
uh these emotions bro so I know like
you've had a hard life Bro you've seen a
lot of people around you just get off
you know but when it happens to someone
just in your circle bro someone's so
close to you like your son it's what
what gave you that strength there's
nothing
there's nothing there's nothing more
painful than to lose your own blood you
know something that is that is from you
like to like I I see a lot of people
when they lose their mouth when they
lose their mom I see them going through
a really difficult time and and they
don't understand that they also when
when when the Sun dies and they make
their mom go through that so that is
it's even worse bro because she had to
carry him she had to see him grow with
when he was not conscious of that she
was taking care of him and I tell a lot
of my homeboys you know like that have
already gone to that pain and I tell
them like you want to give them you want
to give your mom more pain and for a lot
of us like our moms give give they give
us good advice and we don't take it you
know we try we try to play like like
like if we're Invincible like if we're
made of iron but we're not
so hard because there's a lot of people
that
that go go out and they come back in a
bag bro that's great
hmm
subhanallah and you know we had this one
uh comment I wanted to see if you want
to answer this so someone wrote uh Katie
wrote salaam alaikum alhamdulillah I'm
excited to hear from you brother Zach
tell us about your journey for the past
year did you start double for inmates
because you know you did give us that
update last week how's that going
so we we did get we did get uh the
material that we had here we I did get
um I did get it to introduce to the
prisons the we couldn't videotape or do
any any of that because of the situation
with covet and the dangers that we we
had run into you know probably a lot of
brothers there's a lot of people in
there that have have
woken up you know at the end of the day
they see reality and and they they start
acknowledging that at the end of the day
there's only one God except didn't they
that's that's what that's the difference
between us and them you know the
monotheism the monotheism religion that
we believe in one God and
they here in Mexico especially in Mexico
and especially with a lot of uh a lot of
the inmates they they do a lot of short
you know they do they have they have
their own beliefs you know because at
the end of the day like they ask these
these things for favors and and it'll do
them the favor you know so there's
nothing to tell them that
what they're not following is not true
because they're they're giving a little
bit of of of
of power or whatever you know they give
they give them the ability to grant them
the gift or whatever they're asking but
they just have them like in the loop you
know it's like where where they're
they're also getting but they're also
getting taken away you know
um so a lot of people need to wake up to
that reality that that they they are not
here to to help us in any way but to
just lead us astray you know
so there has been a lot of a lot of
brothers that have been reading the
material that we've got but right now
we're trying to we're trying to just um
relocate because of the situations that
we've been having here
uh but that's that's about it
is speaking about the situations you
said there were two kidnapping attempts
aren't you going on that what happened
how did it even happen
like I had already noticed you know that
they were following us and
for a moment I thought that it was like
the cartels or something though but then
I was like you know like they don't they
don't work like that they're not gonna
waste their time or just following you
they're gonna just that's the first
attempt they have they're gonna they're
gonna make sure that you you get you get
put in ice you know but
I knew it was like they they wanted
something from from because the times
are difficult down here brother and in
Mexico there's a lot of kidnappings you
know
um and at the end of the day like Allah
showed me where it was coming from and
then it was from someone that we had to
share dollar to that was supposedly
close to the family you know
um
but the first time that they attempted
was that outside of a Walmart you know I
got a little bit heated up but
alhamdulillah we were able to to get
saved back home but
um when that happened she hadn't she had
to leave the next day
uh I I had to like basically like lay
low for a second for a couple of months
because of the of what was going on
so that that's how the first attempt
happened and then um we had already lost
our son and uh they they tried a
kidnapping again but this time they were
just trying to grab me because they
noticed I think that because we I
wouldn't take her out that often like
before
um and they would see that it was only
me going out
um and they they try to they they tried
to catch me but only a lot we were able
to get away but it was it was like they
were getting desperate that they were
able to to actually do something to us
but that's why like sometimes
we live in a bubble and we think that
that Allah is always going to protect us
but we have to take care of ourselves as
well you know we have to be conscious of
what we're doing of our surroundings of
what are we feeding ourselves with you
know because like I tell my wife
sometimes like you know if I didn't if I
wasn't always thinking about or
reminding myself about um about the the
the reality of where we live in and how
things are here and and I live like in
in my little bubble we're gonna run into
harm and and sometimes it's because we
are not we're not awake we're just like
just pay attention to our phones and
we're gonna we're about to crash into a
pool and we don't even notice you know
we regret it later but why regret later
bro if we can if we could take care of
ourselves right now
so why were these people trying to
kidnap you bro
because of
because of the uh this person that I was
telling you they had seen my that my
wife wasn't from from Mexico or she was
from the UK and they they also spoke
English you know and here in Mexico
anybody from the from Europe I have
money so if they weren't like they did
that's that's their point trying to get
money from from the family's extortion
and all that you know
but they at the end of the day didn't
really know
that like it wasn't like that but like I
told my wife they just hear your accent
or like they they see that you're not
from the U.S
they're gonna they're gonna see a money
sign on it because that's how that's how
things worked on him you know
but alhamdulillah is he has taken care
of us
that's crazy bro
how's your how's your wife been in this
whole situation
she's also been having like she's she
suffered a lot with the loss that we had
and like I tell her like
how can you compare your pain with with
mothers that have lost their kids at 18
20 21. that they they've they've
nurtured them and they've taken care of
them all their life you know
like you can't compare your pain to that
to knowing that a law was so merciful
that he he kept our childhood from
suffering for coming from coming to this
Dunya you know sometimes we don't think
we sometimes we don't realize that this
world goes around like sometimes we're
in a good position
and sometimes we're going to go down to
our extreme extreme bad position you
know but we have we all we always have
to remember that it's a test this is
this is not going to be this is not
going to be easy you know
hmm can you can you go into that that
bubble analogy that you were talking
about bro a lot of men this is a little
bit about what me you and anho were
talking about on the phone you know we
don't have to talk about everything in
depth but just just some of the the
values and lessons bro how like most men
today are just asleep bro and they don't
realize that we got to wake up and and
to be prepared bro
yeah
it's funny how this this Society is is
leading us to just feel comfortable you
know and well we we feel we're feeling
comfortable we're losing the the reality
of taking care of us as as as men you
know as as being strong as being united
and speaking because nowadays they they
have they have that that point of view
that that the man is strong the man
should always bottle up whatever he
feels and and it's not like that you
know that's why we're we're brothers
we're brothers in Islam where we can we
can we can say our problems and we we
have people we have someone to talk to
um and men in reality bro like the way
that there's a lot of men nowadays
it's it's just saddening you know how
how they're corrupting our men because
men nowadays you see them on health you
know not not staying strong and taking
care of what of what Allah has given
them you know and and that's one of one
of the most important things that we
have to that we have to take care of is
our mind and and our
our inner feelings towards this world
you know that we shouldn't Fallen longer
we shouldn't Chase what's in this Dunya
that whatever is given to us that we use
it as a blessing to other people and not
a lot of success to one itself because
uh I see a lot of I see a lot of my
brothers that they'd be chasing you know
they'd be trying to hustle and they'll
be trying to grinding they're trying to
get their money you know but at the end
of the day they tell them like it's not
all about money my bro it's not all
about money because men men they have an
important role in in
the Muslim household you know
and at the end of the day we are the
ones that are going to defend our our
Muslim brothers and brothers and
families you know that's that's the
secret thing right there my brother
but yeah it's it's it's so reality check
to to tell everybody that they have to
keep their guard up you know
[Music]
around me bro you got anything on your
mind it's just me you know I've been
hogging it yeah yeah I um it's kind of
love with with this last discussion of
the you know men not being men I was
actually thinking about this really
recently and I was telling my siblings
about it like
I I've been watching some of these like
you know surviving in the wilderness
videos not stuff where someone goes
through like nothing and they like build
a little Hut and they survive in the
wood and I'm aware that most of them are
probably fake I get it but it really
puts into perspective that for the last
like 200 000 years or however long
humans been alive they did not live the
way we lived they did not have air
conditioning and heating systems and
electricity and and most of the world
still doesn't have the stuff by the way
it's just like in the west and and in
more um uh you know first world country
maybe second world country as well the
third world countries other places
they're struggling you know people today
still live like
people lived like hundreds of years ago
so yeah we see this as a blessing it is
but what does it do at the same time at
the same time it makes everything so
easy for us that we don't have the
adversity of having to even make our own
food if you have money you just ubereats
or your mom will make you something like
it's it's made us regress so much
especially as men and I think this is
another reason why women are kind of you
know stepping up and and men are
regressing because a lot of them are
still doing the things that we're doing
50 years ago you know dressing up and
looking cute and looking nice and and
whatever just now now there's like a
kind of entrepreneurial perspective
added for them in a more like empowering
what they call it perspective added for
them but I think they're losing it as
well but for men
they have nothing even socializing this
is all you need to do you don't even
have to leave your house is all you need
to socialize so it all it does is
propagate and make weak men and I
genuinely think that brother Ali I can
only say this about myself is a lot
stronger than I am because of what he's
been through and now that I've I've
thought about it in from this
perspective I can say that firmly like
just because he's been through so and
I'm saying I say just because I don't
mean like it's a small thing but the
fact that he's been through more he's
experienced more and he's had you know
that experience and stuff that changes a
person to really be a man and uh a part
of me is you know almost envious of that
may Allah bless you brother and make us
all men I mean
and it's it's true you know sometimes we
need um
get back in contact with with
um with nature you know like as men we
should we should try to to look for the
that uh
how do you say that Recreation of going
to climbing a hill you know getting back
in hiking getting getting strong in in
places where where we're not
um
you know it was a blessing coming down
here to Mexico because when I was
younger you I had a comfortable life I
had never had a goal for water or how to
go look and know how to use an ax you
know or a machete or writer even a horse
room and down in the South like that's
where where you learn it in this is
where there's these these types of small
communities where they they're still
living like they were living three
thousand years ago you know and it it it
makes you strong why do you think like a
lot of our brothers like khabib like all
these Russian Fighters that are coming
to dominate the sport they're all coming
from the mountains where there's
basically nothing you know that's why
they're physically strong and sometimes
we need a we need to lose the commodity
to to to get a Little Bit Stronger you
know
um 100 yeah
go ahead bro no I'm just gonna say this
is true in every Avenue of life it's not
it's not just with physical it's with
mental with emotional you will not be
able to handle emotionally draining
situations unless you've been in
emotionally draining situations just
like you know they use the they always
use this um analogy of when you're
working out you know you lift heavy
weights you're breaking down your muscle
you're really breaking tearing up your
muscle and so it can rebuild itself
basically stronger it can repair itself
stronger but that's the truth with any
Avenue of life
but what were you gonna say bro
I was gonna say man like with this being
said
what is the advice that you would give
to other brothers or what's what's the
advice that maybe you would give to
yourself
uh had you not had gone through all this
maybe you were just like in in that
comfortable place that you were before
you know
you know I get I asked a lot from from
other people that talk to me or that
know me
that I see my brother I put him as an
example because you know we both grew up
as kids in the US he decided to stay
over there I came over here to Mexico
and I see him you know and and I see how
he he ended up when he was younger he
was skinny and he was bragging because
he had a nice body and now he he got the
extra kilos you know because he he's
lived a comfortable life and he's asking
how has it that you killed yourself like
slim I said you know I've had a I have a
I've always liked to take care of myself
then I've always practiced some good
sports you know uh we have to get out
there we try to find that that cardio
that we that we need as men you know and
cardio bro does a lot of benefit from
for the man in itself
no and and nowadays like like Rami said
like we'll go with drive and we become
so lazy bro and and if most of us will
have to run or have to check our cardio
most of us have our cardio really low so
I think that's that's a good that's some
good advice for any of our brothers you
know a little bit of cardio to get that
heart pumping and to actually oxygen put
oxygen in our in our minds you know
because then we we have to conquer our
mind bro after before anything else we
it's it's a mind it's a mind thing you
know you you dominate the mind and
everything comes out everything else
comes in control
but it's it's a war bro
but I'm saying man like if you have
these these brothers who live in very
comfortable houses
um they just for like a bit of words are
soft and um if they were trying to just
become more tougher
um they were trying to learn how to I
guess you could say
survive without all these luxuries and
stuff like that what would be like some
actual realistic steps that these people
can take I know running is something
good for the mind as well but like what
else would you recommend here
um like in what sort of way like I I
don't understand your question bro
yeah my bad my bad maybe I'm not uh
phrasing it correctly but Romney was
saying uh your situation overall what
you've been through it shows the
development that has occurred in your
life because
yeah and that development is different
than the development that Romney has had
now you two are at two different levels
you two are both Muslim and it's not to
say that you're you're Superior or that
ROM is a serious it's just to say that
from experience you have this certain
experience around me has this certain
experience therefore if something were
to occur you are for the most part
more better off in that in that
occurrence because you have the
experience whereas Romney doesn't have
the experience so it might just be
difficult more difficult for him and so
the question is like someone who doesn't
have these kinds of experiences someone
who's basically been shelter who's been
in a very comfortable environment their
entire life like how could they go about
basically
getting the morning
obtain obtaining that knowledge like he
was saying he was watching those videos
of how to survive in the wilderness but
basically it's that you know it's it's
whatever you want you want to put your
attention towards and like whatever you
want to learn in itself to prepare you
psychological world because it could you
could there is nothing that could
prepare you actually for whatever
whatever type of scenario uh we have to
encounter you know and even my even
myself and I say this for what I've seen
in in many riots in prison and how
people that were more that were like
that you would think that wouldn't
wouldn't react in a positive way or or
towards Defending Your Life or to
protecting your like your security uh
that you thought they were going to go
running and hired other ones that are
ready to protect you you know the people
that that talk a lot and don't really
put in that action to the first ones to
run out so
um it's it's all about
getting mentally prepared for those
situations you know and and knowing at
the end of the day what is it that you
are trying to prepare yourself for
um
so you don't think there's actual
physical preparation that's coming with
it as well what what like every I think
every every every man should learn how
to defend himself and defend his family
right so any type of context or any type
of of wrestling sport I I would that's
what I would recommend and
like I tell people that and I tell
people that I've had like problems with
back in the day I would tell them like
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fight with
you I'm not gonna stab you I'm gonna put
on my gun and just give you that because
that's that's not gonna make the problem
bigger it's just gonna take care of the
problem and by itself so if I'm gonna if
I'm gonna decide to practice any sports
I'm not gonna do it with the intentions
of killing the person you know I have
the I need to have that respect of
knowing that where I'm I need to force
myself and I need to push him to get
better at whatever whatever I want to
work in you know like um regarding
regarding uh an example kickboxing if
you want to get better at kickboxing you
have to look for those those people that
are going to push you to that limit that
you have to defend yourself because if
you're just going around bullying a
bunch of little kids you're not you're
gonna think that you're really good at
kickboxing but you're not gonna you're
not gonna learn anything you're going to
feel comfortable with yourself because
you know that you you've done it right
but it's not going to make you grow and
the only way that that the man or the
human being grows is under pressure you
know so we always have to go in in
regarding this regarding these Sports
because I know that there's a lot of
people that don't that can't practice it
they're mentally not not capable of
practicing because they're the people
that will try to hurt you you know in in
a sparring session or whatever whatever
is it that you're practicing they don't
have that respect towards the the other
person to to know that at the end of the
day it's just uh it's just um a way of
of keeping your body healthy and it's
you're not doing it in the way that
you're trying to hurt the other person
no you're not going to actual War to
take care to make sure this guy doesn't
get up but
a lot of people don't understand that
that in order for you to grow you have
to you have to you have to be pressured
but by that that we have to hang around
with brothers that would push us to that
limit you know that would make us like
let's say that you you go run an hour
and rummy and fires only run half an
hour you have to pull them and make them
run the hour with you you know that's
the only way that they're going to get
stronger and you're gonna push yourself
so I think that's that's a that's a
perfect way of of of obtaining what was
has been taken away from the from us as
as human as Anna says Muslims bro you
know because we became real we've we've
become really weak bro in reality we
might think we know a lot but we don't
take care of this first you know
we think that just knowledge is going to
make us Superior than other than in what
we have to do but we have to take we
also have to take care of our body you
know nowadays I don't I don't see that
like getting promoted out there you know
that we as men have to take care of our
bodies because we as men have to have to
take care of our families and that's
what I was telling you uh yesterday
about
um that I'm about how the woman the
woman's role in in the with the with the
with the men's with the man is you know
that at the end of the day when danger
has you in front of you with your with
with your spouse or with your wife at
the end who's going to one responsible
of taking care of the spouse you know of
the woman because we know that the woman
is by nature she is she's weaker than us
you know in in in other aspects and a
man in his role he would have to defend
his wife you know and I guess I think
that that's why we have we have a lot of
responsibility in in us to get that
respect that we deserve you know because
nowadays
they think that and I say it's because
of a lot of people you know people think
that they deserve this respect you know
you give respect to to receive respect
you know if you have to treat others how
you want to be treated so if if you're
not if if you're not treating other
people that way then I think that's
that's uh
that's something that we as men also
have to work on respect and not just not
just around us Muslims you know not
because I have a different a different
point of view than the other brother I'm
gonna I'm gonna disrespect him you know
I'm not but as well with with our with
our enemies you know with people that
are not Muslims people that attackers
you know
we have to show that we are more
knowledgeable than them and that we can
we can act like men you know and and
speaking and have and have an argument
but with with respect without
disrespecting ourselves and without
disrespecting them
[Music]
um
so you had mentioned that
you know you you said the example of
like if I'm running an hour and then run
me a fight only around 30 minutes then I
got to be the one to pull them so they
can run the full hour yeah
um this is why this is why it's so
important to have like
a community or like a tribe or something
like this and this is why the prophet
Muhammad
said that you know the people around you
is very important and that if you you
know if if it's bad company that's
around you then it's better to be alone
but if it's a good company around you
then it's better to be with them than to
be alone so my question for you bro
would you say you've had that good
company around you or would you say that
it hasn't really been like that
um I've had a good company of having
kids that have trained with me here and
that they have learned a little bit of
Islam uh sadly they for the first for
circumstances that we don't control
they've had a move and I've I've been
keeping myself to myself but I'm I'm in
I'm in that point where I'm already
gonna move into a different state with
an indigenous population that have
accepted Islam
um and we're going to do our best down
there you know try to uh
my mentality is being down there in the
South you know and being in contact with
these brothers uh seeing if we could put
a gym anything out there to keep our
keep our our youth are youth active you
know because nowadays it's just grabbing
the PlayStation and playing Warzone you
know whatever whatever they want on the
controller instead of actually doing
that physical work that we need getting
ourselves strong you know for for any
case yeah all right so before I ask you
about that I wanted to ask you in the
situation now since you're more alone
like what have you been doing in this
time alone to like be care and be able
to take care of everything for yourself
and now that I've that I've been by
myself it's it's been more like
when when you're by yourself you can you
can meditate you know and think about
the things that you need to work in
criticize yourself you know like because
we can't criticize anybody else because
at the end of the day you're the only
one that's responsible for your actions
so the only way that you're going to
grow is by acknowledging what's wrong
and what is it that you need to get
stronger in that that could be one point
um that I've worked on a lot
um just reflecting you know and and
actually pondering on what we what we
read you know what we read what we read
every day what what information we're
putting into our bodies what what it
what blessings we're putting into our
bodies and and how is it that we can
we can work our way out of this this
Society world because this Society has
nothing good for us you know
the the
I I see it that way bro I'm the type of
person that instead of being in in the
spotlight I'd rather go into the
mountains you know I think I feel I
would live a more comfortable life than
than to accept the Commodities because
um like my wife's family they asked me
you should come to Manchester you should
you should come live over here in in the
UK it's it's better you know it's it's
better in the way that you're gonna be
you're gonna have more Comfort you're
gonna have but inside of me I say like I
don't want to go there because at the
end of the day like easy times make weak
men you know Hard Times make will make
strong men and that's why like we use an
example the Taliban the Taliban they've
had 14 Empires bro 14 armies going to
their into their into their land you
know and try to take their land and 14
14 half fell brother you know that
there's some strong strong Muslims down
there in Afghanistan but that's that's
how you could actually see the
difference you know that they've had
they've was still 14 14 armies from 14
different nations and 14 have failed to
to take what what they have been given
by Allah you know they'll defend and
that's why they're strong and they they
don't have Commodities like we do you
know I've seen these these documentaries
of how they they're living up there and
how they live in in very rural places so
all around the world it's like they're
they live a more simple life and a more
happier life and I think sometimes
um you have to remember the examples of
our profit no peace be upon them and we
have to stay humble bro we can't let we
can't let none of these these small
Commodities these small things to take
to take the to take away the the tension
of what really what really matters you
know and if they're reminding the
reminding ourselves that
that we serve a lot you know that when
this life is just it's just temporary
sometimes we we think or we say to
ourselves oh tomorrow I'll get to it or
or I still have time I'm still gonna I'm
still gonna be able to to to do what I
need to do you know we we we let it
extend we let it extend when in reality
we don't nothing is secure bro and at
the at the time when we least expect it
is we get a wake-up call or it's too
late you know alhamdulillah I've had
those wake-up calls you know and I'm
honestly I don't
I don't follow depression or anything
like that brother because like I know
that why things are happening you know I
know why
alhamdulillah Allah has has placed me in
this place because now I I have a
I have a meaning towards why I should
why why I should stay alive you know why
should why should I fight for for
keeping myself healthy for for keeping
myself out of harm and uh for trying for
trying to find something different in
life you know because
to a lot of a lot of people down here in
the South a lot of people I don't know
about our religion first of all they
don't know they don't even know what it
is you know and and they don't they
don't they can't
they'll never they'll never grow as a
society if we don't introduce our
religion except the end of the day our
religion has saved the West our religion
has given a lot to this to this uh to to
the world you know and we need to get
those Golden Ages back bro
thanks bro
so how do you feel about moving down to
this uh southern part that you were
speaking of I can't wait brother
I tell my wife like I'm gonna buy myself
a horse
you're like why do you want a horse I'm
like because we're gonna we're gonna be
in the mountains you know because that's
what I'm looking for I'm looking to be
in contact with my with what Allah has
placed here to to ponder on you know and
and to to get strong as a human being
because sometimes being in the city for
me bro it's like
it's all right but I see a lot of
distractions and when regarding to you
have to focus what in what really
matters you know
and at the end of the day what really
matters is your academic not this life
this life is it's just temporarily and
sometimes we we think that we have a lot
of time or we think that we're we're
getting so blessed that we we're we get
comfortable bro and it has to be like an
everyday reminder of feeling that
uncomfortable like when the prophet was
pleasing upon him when he was laying in
his mat you know and one of his
companions came up to him and he saw how
the map had his his
the mark of where he was laying down you
know
it's more reminder of those small things
that we are here in in a temporarily
world at the end of the day our academic
is more important than anything here
that we cannot let that be we cannot let
that be um overshine for whatever
whatever that this Dunya has to offer us
you know
um and sometimes it's that's why it's
but sometimes I've not I've
I've been happy bro to to be able to see
that and and in a lot of ways you know
like just to be able to see that at the
end of the day like this side is gonna
throw a lot at you and it's going to
want to make you want to make you feel
like you're prospering because you're
you have no difficulties you have no
nothing is uncomfortable for you but
when you feel like that you have to
worry you have to worry because Comfort
is not good feeling comfortable is not
good you know because you don't grow as
a human being like like Ronnie said it's
it's it's
it's that pressure that we have to put
ourselves in and and that uh on
comfortness to actually grow and to
actually
grow in in both ways there's physical
and in the mental way because nowadays
sometimes we get just um lost in that in
in that physical thing you know looking
for that physical that physical growth
and that physical benefit trying to look
good when we're growing it we're going
to grow old we're gonna we're gonna get
we're going to get weak and we're gonna
this our life is gonna be in in a Flash
you know and we just get obsessed with
with what what Allah has blessed us with
that we forget that our mentality is
more important it's important as well
you know and then we have to balance it
you know in a healthy way to to keep
ourselves reminding ourselves that this
is just this is just a a small trip you
know that this that nothing here is is
gonna stay and
we are not we are not secured anything
for tomorrow
this life is just a test bro but how
many of us are just constantly aware
that it is a test we get just caught up
in this temporary delusion bro so I
wanted to ask you about you know the
state of men that are in the west like
brother was talking about everyone has
these Commodities everyone has Comfort
everyone has just you know easy access
to food like Rami was saying you know
you're at the at the you just you just
tap a button bro and you just get food
delivered to you bro so I wanted to ask
you what you think about the state of
the West is in and what where you see
America go but before that I have a
video that I wanted to play for you
um we've already reacted to this video
in the past but uh I just want to get
your thoughts on this video bro all
right
foreign
I like to think I've been defending
freedom from an early age
to marry my other mom
with such powerful Role Models I
finished high school at the top of my
class and after meeting with an army
recruiter
I found it a way to prove my inner
strength I'm U.S army Corporal Emma
Malone Lord and I answered my calling
there you go bro that's the Russian
versus U.S Army recruitment
that's what they stand for my brother
easy as that you know it's what they
stand for in their their
how do you say they're um
their values are you know
um and that's why we have to put it we
have to put a lot of attention to to
what we know as Muslims and into what we
know that what's trying to be Usher in
you know we have to see all around our
how everything's changing how things are
getting are getting into a bad spot bro
sometimes we don't want to realize it
but but we have to we have to make sure
of what's going on around us you know
not not to the point that you're going
to be like um going crazy over it or or
or just like losing your mind over you
know you have to be you have to be
acknowledging what's going on in actual
and actually be prepared mentally to be
ready for in case of anything if
anything that's gonna change our way of
life or good for a cold for a quick
wake-up call you know but yeah that's
that's what I see right there is you
know that what each side represents
the what we what we know about them you
know
now what are your thoughts on the coming
of the gel bro because if the gel is
something you know the prophet saw
mentioned this is going to be a test
that it's inescapable bro when the jail
comes you better hope that you're not
here bro to deal with the job now we
know that there's going to be specific
places in the world like let's say makka
and Medina where the gel can enter you
know so do you think as Muslim men that
we should make Hijra and we should
actually leave the West bro or do you
think we should essentially just stay
here and just hold our ground no yeah
it's it's like
I have that opinion but not I don't like
I know a lot of people are not going to
accept whatever way whatever I have to
say you know or or take in a good way
but it's just my opinion yes as well
like if you think opposite I'm gonna
respect I'm not going to say anything
about it but you're gonna stand with
with the people that you that you that
you know that have the same belief as
you know why would you stay in a country
where we're all we're seeing all this
like we're seeing in the news about
Balenciaga about Kanye West how much
garbage they're putting into into our
into our our minds because at the end we
have to we have to listen to it we know
we have to digest it and sometimes like
you have to be careful of what you're
you're digesting or what your what
information you're getting fed you know
because
like I I see that and and like I think
that the real Muslims are going to be
able to tell right away what's what is
it that they're cooking you know
and I I believe that they're trying to
Usher that in as fast as possible
because of of how things are are working
around it and we have to be we have to
wake up from from thinking that these
things that we're not going to live on
you know we have to wake up and we have
to be ready for for anything that's
going to happen because
it's it's it's something that a lot of
us don't want to talk about bro we just
rather have in the back of our mind you
know worry about like just worry about
how comfortable we're living and where
where we're at the tension we're getting
in it's not about that it's about
actually paying attention to the small
signs that are that we're seeing popping
up everywhere bro you know and the the
job is something that that the West is
preparing very very carefully like a lot
of people say like how are you going to
think how are you gonna like this how
many I have friends that I have
sometimes discussions about this and um
they're Christians you know and they're
like how do you think that how do you
think that they're gonna they're gonna
um destroy themselves destroy their
Nation
but they don't really care about you you
know they don't really care about the
people that that are that are in their
Nation you know there's a scary thing
that they say that a thousand years ago
it was easier to control people by
religion you know it was easier to
manipulate their minds and now we're
living in a time where it's easier to
kill a thousand people you know it's way
easier to kill a lot of people into
control them by the ideology so we gotta
we gotta wake up because things are
changing and if we don't make those
movements you know that we need to make
to
to know where we're gonna where we're
heading at the end of the day you know
like I myself like I'm heading to the
South and everything but like I intend
to go to to parts of Africa that are
close to Medina you know to the to the
Southern Southern Arabia Peninsula I
think that's my that's my actual view
you know and maybe some people are gonna
say oh you're over dramatic or you're
taking things to the extreme I'm not
saying I want to remove right now you
know I'm saying that eventually I'm
that's where I'm going to want to be
leading myself to you know that's what
I'm going to be able to
that's what I'm going to be able to try
to push myself towards because I know
that how everything is going to go down
it's going to be it's going to be like
that bro but we have to we also have to
understand that we don't control how
things are going to go down you know we
can only be prepared we know we can only
be ready but at the end of the day it's
good what a lot of what allow girls is
going to happen that's what I I see
these I see these movements of
[Music]
um
the
these people are trying to usher in the
the job you know and the way the way
that we've that we have that we know
that a lot of things are going to go
down like I tell them I tell my wife
like they they have their plans and
they're ushering their way but only it's
gonna at the end of the day it's gonna
happen like a lot of sense you know
so we we have to be really careful
because after
I'm pretty sure after this year bro
things are gonna get upside down you
know things are going to change for a
lot of people a lot of people don't
don't want to wake up to the reality of
how things are working right now
yeah bro this reminds me of
um
conversations that I have with uh fire
and Romney
and it's this thing that I've been like
just kind of playing with them in my
head and this idea and it's the idea of
Hijra and I was you know I was reading
these things and watching a lot of
videos and this person that I was
watching they were saying that
a lot of times people think they don't
have to move they don't have to make
Hijra to like the lands that are closer
to the holy lands where the Kaaba is
where Mecca Medina are and they think
this way because they've been living in
said place for so time they're
comfortable or it's like they just
they basically assimilate it they've
assimilated into the environment that
they're in you know like they've become
part of it and the environment is not
part of them
where the way they think is a direct
result of the environment like if you
live in the west you've been living
there your entire life you can't say
that the ideologies that the different
philosophies and the ways of thinking
and all this stuff you can't say that
that has not infected your way of
thinking you cannot say that the way
that you think right now is completely
different and it doesn't align with the
West you could have different things you
could want to think differently but it
doesn't change the fact that
subconsciously you have programming that
has been instilled in you since you were
a little kid
that is bro it's crazy the thing that I
read that like hit me the most was the
fact that when people are in these
environments when you have these
ideologies that are programmed into you
even if you think you're doing things
better even if you're a Muslim and
you're practicing in your own Deen what
ends up happening is that there's
psychological blocks that stop you from
getting closer to Allah and stops you
from going deeper into your theme and
it's upon a lot bro it's
it's crazy bro we have we have this we
have this brother bro by the name of
Hamza he has a YouTube channel too and
he's been he's been mentioning for the
last couple months bro that he feels
this block bro of reading the Quran you
know and me and Anna were talking about
this he just he just feels like he wants
to read the Quran but there's just
something there that's literally like a
block like on house saying you know and
he's in the UK bro he's deep in the UK
living amongst these societies of the
Westborough and the propaganda and when
he moved to Dubai bro very quickly after
moving to Dubai listening to the Adan
every single morning listening to the
prayers it's very easy now to get rid of
that block and he started reading Quran
we have to understand that that um
everything is moved to frequencies bro
and times are changing they usually in
this 5G this 5G internet you know
they're giving you this fast supposedly
internet but in reality we have to we
have to know that these antennas are
causing harm to the human being even the
people that are working with these
antennas are complaining about getting
burned about having cancer developing
cancer from these things
um and I think there are definitely
there's a black bro there's black
because they they they want to keep us
asleep and a lot of us don't want to
wake up because that's that's how how
hard and difficult it is you know to
wake us up but I think that it's that's
part of the test bro because if if the
test was easy and anybody could could
graduate I think it would be a lot of
them and at the end of the day we ask a
lot of beef of the few you know I'm a
few that can actually see how things are
are for what they are you know bro and
and not fall in love with the with with
what this Dunya can give us discomfort
that we can we can receive with this
technology that we're having nowadays
because I I see I don't think technology
as a bad thing but it could be used in
the in the double it has a it's a
double-edged sword you know it can cause
a lot of benefit and it can cause a lot
of harm and sometimes that harm is
caused unconsciously bro you know like
if if you're going if you grab your
phone and you go into YouTube sometimes
we see we see these uh these commercials
that are being
put down our throat but we have to
listen to them you know like small
little examples that we see nowadays the
just the just the media bro just the
information that we're getting like it's
it's like you see it and you're like you
know that if the information is fake but
why are you still why are you still
consuming that information you know it
hasn't a lot giving you a brain to to do
your own research and get your own
conclusions we have that knowledge to be
able to get our information and and see
if it's going to be if it's benefit if
it's beneficial or if it's not because
nowadays you look at the Western media
and everything you see is is preparing
you for something that they're gonna
have to accept by the end of the day you
know but the true muscles that I
recommended to start planning their
their way towards more Muslims you know
because that's the only way that we're
going to be able to to be strong and to
stand strong
is being a little bit Muslims
all right you think bro aside from the
the whole technology and frequencies and
everything we're talking about another
big thing is the food bro
I thought you were going to bring that
in when you were talking about hunting
because I was also going to tell you
like we have to be careful what we're
eating bro
what they're trying to put into our
systems you know
that's why it's better
to try to to try to break away from from
this from this uh this type of Matrix
that they're trying to put around us
because at the end of the day they're
controlling what you see they're
controlling what you hear they're
controlling what you eat and what you
eat is really important bro like you've
seen how many things are coming into our
Foods you know how many like even the
water that we're drinking is causing us
harm bro so we need to we need to wake
up and we need to we need a question
that you know we need to try to find a
solution to to those type of problems
that were that we we have to see you
know because that's very important that
the man has to
has to give themselves a reminder of
what is it that he's feeding himself you
know hmm
what is it that you think about that
about what they're putting in our Foods
I think bro with all the GMOs with all
the pesticides with all the hormones
with all the antibiotics and all this
type of nonsense that they're feeding us
bro they've it's not a little like even
as a kid bra would question these things
bro because I wasn't woke as a kid no
one knew these things you know obviously
when we were younger because we were
just products of the school system you
know but even in the school system I
would wonder like bro why is a Big Mac
at McDonald's a dollar or two dollars
but then if you want to stop at
McDonald's it's like 10 bucks bro why is
healthy food so much more expensive but
then this cheap trash is just so like
it's a dollar two dollars you know and I
would always wonder that growing up and
I would always ask my parents too
sometimes I would you know in the school
system they would tell us you know oh
it's actually like it's it's it's it's
actually you know more expensive to eat
out it's more expensive to to eat you
know outside food at restaurants but
then when I actually started Living by
myself now paying bills and and buying
food and struggling you know like a lot
of these brothers and I'm realizing bro
like if you want to actually eat clean
that's what's expensive bro if you want
to buy good quality meat if you want to
buy good quality fish if you want to buy
vegetables that's what's pricey bro it's
cheap and easy bro if you want to just
eat trash from outside
so and it's so easy to find the habits
bro because sometimes just because it's
something tastes good doesn't mean that
that's going to be beneficial for us you
know we might think oh it's it's we're
going to avoid the cooking we're going
to avoid the process of wasting our time
and finding something healthy for us we
can just pick up something that we know
that we like to eat but when you're in
the bathroom or when you actually paying
attention to what you're eating you're
like this is garbage you know why am I
eating this if this is garbage yeah yeah
and I think this is where we can see
that a lot of our our men are getting
sick from you know diabetes we see we
see younger men getting diabetes we see
people having problems with their
cholesterol we see people having Strokes
at really young ages bro because they're
not taking care of themselves anymore my
brother you know
it's just crazy how expensive it is man
like if I wanted to just do meat fruit
and honey
oh man that gets expensive real quick
with
what's going on with
how with all the methods these people
have made you know since they since the
sanctions to Russia and and everything
just getting out of hand
it's it said they want you to take what
they give you
at the end of the day that's what's
gonna happen that you're gonna take
whatever it's given to you because it's
going to be so high it's going to be so
it's going to be so costly that you're
gonna have to accept if everyone's help
and you know that that these governments
don't stand for anything that's
righteous you know they don't stand for
anything that's that is good that the
contrary they they wanna
they want to usher in that
that thing and I think that that's why
lately we have I've been noticing a lot
of like um
I've noticed a lot like uh in the sort
of way that they're letting themselves
be seen for what they are and we can
make a lot of noise of what they're
doing but what you're not gonna do
anything about it you know nobody does
anything about it nobody has done
anything about it since since how far
how for how long has this been going on
and and you're saying that you're waking
up but at the end of the day you're not
doing anything about it you know it's
still going to happen you're not gonna
have the control to do anything yeah
it's a system to tell you to tell you
that that you have to wake up that
you're under their control not not that
you're that you're actually working it's
a slap in the face bro it's a kick in
the face exactly it's a step in the face
you know the thing about this
but think about this right it's not just
a slap in the face it's more like they
they're throwing you down the ground
they got their foot on your neck because
the first let's say you don't have the
money all right well then it's like you
only look for the cheap options and and
all the cheap options like you can
survive you can eat food with cheap but
it's like you're not getting anything
that's proper nutrition you're not
getting anything that's like really good
in like actually nourishing for your
body now let's say you do have money
here's where it starts to go around full
circle let's say you do have money and
you're going out there and you're buying
like grass-fed Halal beef Halal shape
um chicken though liver all the organ
Meats you're buying fruits you're buying
veggies but it's like all like organic
like high quality stuff well listen
you're still part of the system they've
still got their foot on your neck
because the moment that everything goes
downhill like you've basically been
paying for that you still don't know how
to actually get this food on your own
my dad used to tell me when I was a kid
he used to say um
well I can't say in Spanish but you're
understanding but no one else will
understand it
no no I could I could translate it but I
mean like if you want me in Spanish
and the whole like translated means um
my dad would say I could give you like a
fish
every single day
for the rest of your life and you would
eat good but the moment that I die
you're dying with me because you don't
know how to fish
but if I teach you how to fish well then
the moment I die you continue to live
and those that you give birth to
continue to live as well because they
also will learn how to fish and that
that's what basically they're taking
away from us bro they're taking our
nature and they're making up these
these beings that are just consuming
and not really
acknowledging what what what we have as
as humans you know as blessings that
Allah has given us we don't we rather
just shut off and and be comfortable
than to actually learn these things and
and get out there and uh and be ready
for anything that at the end of the day
that's what I'm kind of I'm trying to
push myself towards towards the
disconnection of of whatever that system
is you know to not be to not have to
depend on them to not have to do
anything regarding food anything
regarding their system like to not
depend on them you know at the end they
you know that it's gonna crash but
you're gonna be able to move yourself
and get you get yourself where you need
to get yourself you know
because bro like that's what I've been
thinking lately and I've been telling my
brother because my brother's in the
states and I tell them like hey just be
careful you know
um and he because because I I was
telling this I was telling him what's
going on right now like back in in May
and I'll sign him you know just get
ready because things are not looking
good and he didn't believe me he was
like no I got my job and everything and
he lost his job lately and he hasn't
been working for like three weeks
everything's getting really expensive
his his uh his children got sick he had
to take him to the hospital
there's been there's been a lot a lot of
things happening and I tell him hey be
careful bro because I know how people
act when when they're putting that point
of stress and
if you let yourself
get stuck or get like falling in shock
you're dead you know so you need to be
aware of that how things could how ugly
things can get and how fast things can
get and you need to be already prepared
to know what you're like what is it that
you're going to do to protect your your
your loved ones you know that you can
only protect the ones that are with you
bro
protect yourself and protect your your
um daughter and your daughters and and
your wife you know don't worry about
anybody else don't worry about anybody
else that's far away from you no because
at the end of the day your neighbors
will be will be trying to take whatever
you have that's how desperate it's gonna
get and people don't realize that that
it's gonna get like that or you're gonna
have to get into their system
that's how I see things that are falling
falling in right now you know
um it's crazy bro and no I think the
West is going to have a a really rude
awakening in regards to that that type
of stuff because we have to realize that
the economy is not strong you know the
economy right now for for the US
it's really bad especially for Europe
I've seen a lot of like people in the UK
right now are struggling bro they're
struggling with with everything right
now and it's it's the the life the
the way of life is not like it was
before you know
and a lot of people say no it's okay
we're gonna it's gonna get it's gonna
it's gonna come back to it's gonna get
back to to normal
but in reality we need to we need to
inform what's going out there and we
need to get informed of real real news
and not keep keep on taking this Western
media
fake news you know because then they
they want to keep you they want to keep
you like comfortable like telling you oh
nothing's gonna happen everything's
gonna be okay but then when reality
checks they ain't gonna they ain't gonna
let you know because they're they know
where they've been working at and you're
gonna have to make a decision if you're
gonna fall in line how they want you to
be or
because it's it's weird how they're how
how they've been they've been putting
all these camps I don't know if you guys
have heard about the FEMA camps in the
U.S and all that regarding to a natural
disaster
um the vaccines that they want to put on
us in China right now they're they're
they're going back to to lockdown
because of of new of new strengths that
are coming out you know oh man we got to
take care of ourselves brother
that's why we can't even we can't think
that things are going to get normal bro
we can't we can't think like that
because they haven't been normal no
sorry go on bro
oh so someone said a Super Chat thing I
just want to say I love the three Muslim
Brothers may Allah bless us guys
um the come up is real how do we get in
contact with Alice do you have any any
way that people can get in touch with
you like an email or something like that
well it's the same email that I've
always had my brother okay I think you
guys have it here right okay so if you
we'll talk to you after bro if you want
we can put a link in the description
um if people want to get in contact with
you inshallah
yeah
come over no so so one question that I
had bro is hearing everything that
you've been through in the last couple
months you know as a Muslim a lot of
people they they have these trials and
tribulations and they let that kind of
break things for them you know they use
that to kind of lose their faith in God
they use that to kind of Define how you
know I really don't want to like work
hard to be a good Muslim how did you use
these things these hardships these
losses of your loved ones and stay close
to Allah and not let them kind of break
you
it's like
like like I said it's a mind game bro
and you have to you have to wake up and
realize that if you have the blessing to
to see what's going on in your life that
you have been blessed with this religion
and that you know that this life is a
test if you think this test is going to
be easy you're completely wrong if if
you like being comfortable and you like
not being hurt and not grow as a human
being and as a Muslim then this is the
wrong religion for you you know it's
like Christian like Christians tell you
like when you accept Jesus Christ
everything else is going to come
everything else is going to put in order
but it's not like we as Muslims have to
know that this is going to be a trial
you know and and I had to learn it the
hard way when I when I first became a
Muslim I remember I had coveted bro and
it was it was it was scary because I I
didn't go to no hospital or anything but
I did feel like I was gonna die you know
it affected me that bad but because I
have barely accepted Islam I was so
happy that I I could admire might have
left you know I I was glad that I was
gonna gonna die supposedly because I
knew that I was gonna meet my Creator
but um it was like uh it was a reminder
that we could
at times we're gonna the times could
change but at the end of the day we have
to trust in the law bro and that Allah
has to remind like we have to remind
ourselves that just the remembrance of
him and the acknowledging how how things
are moving right now and at the end of
the day he has control over everything
bro you know so just it's like a
reminder when we get tested yeah it
might hurt and it might it might feel it
might make us feel uncomfortable
but unless we don't react in a positive
way and and we make ourselves stronger
then it's only going to make you we get
weaker you know it's like when you get
sick and if you get sick and you don't
if your own your own system doesn't
overcome that your body doesn't get
stronger but if you if you decide to
just because you're feeling bad to
choose the the medication way and start
medicating yourself and start putting
all this garbage inside of you with
you're you're just making your your body
a lot more weaker bro so it's hard it's
hard like there is no easy way out
brother you know there's no easy path
that we're going to be able to take and
and say like oh this is the way it's
it's it's gonna be especially hard for
us Muslims bro
yeah I think there's a Hadith brother
saying that you know this this Dunya bro
it's a prison for the believer
yeah and it is brother yeah
oh it's crazy but it was crazy man is
like in the past when I was a kid and I
was in high school
um anytime I would get sick my mom would
just throw me on like antibiotics or
something like this oh and bro it was
terrible actually I think it like made
my health way way worse like in the long
run but I remember I got to the point
where I learned how bad it was to be
taking medication all the time
especially like the moment you got sick
like boom hopping on medication
so I hadn't made the choice you know I'm
gonna stop taking medication just let my
body begin to build up its own
resilience and be able to actually fight
these things on its own bro I'm not
gonna lie it did suck at first
but now it's like when I get sick my
body just my body takes care of itself
and it takes care of itself in such a
fast way that if I would have compared
to when I was taking antibiotics Not
only was I getting sick more often when
I was taking antibiotics all the time
but it would take me at least minimum
two weeks before I would start feeling
all right from whatever it is that I had
gotten sick with
so it's it's crazy bro it is crazy when
you start to see how like these things
like
they do good for you and in the moment
but they actually do more harm than the
good yeah why do you think that people
that live like like drama was saying
people that have that are living like
they lived before they're stronger than
us bro they got better immune systems
they they have less sicknesses than us
like just even our ancestors how strong
how how strong they would still be
working at Old ages you know and
nowadays like they just get to 50 60
they want to put their shoes away
but it's not like that like in order for
our bodies to keep strong we have to
keep that motion because that motion is
what gives our bodies that life and
we're getting to a society Park
oh no bro this is like the old days bro
brother Jin got him gin bro if you guys
guys links in the description for the
old episodes we had with Brother Ali if
you caught them you already know bro the
Gin were interrupting a lot bro
subhanallah
oh there we go
my back totally
wearing that those jeans things they're
strong enough bro I don't know what's
going on but really
there's this something happened this
last month that there's been a lot of
activity bro
you know and it's getting crazy because
we humans be playing with stuff that we
shouldn't be playing you know because
they want to usher in that time
so bro please
tell us about that about like the Gin
before we wrap up like you know because
people watch the old episode with you
they already know how the cartel use gen
how you you revealed a lot of those
things but has there been anything in
your life bro
So lately lately I've been I've been
reading these interviews with with some
person that I've been in prison and um
he was he was telling me some
information on how the the main the main
bosses of these cartels would eat human
flesh bro and they would eat they would
drink this they would drink their blood
in there but it all has to do with that
bro it all has to do with that with that
type of that those type of entities that
are that are that are that wanted us to
to stray away you know
um
right now with with that regarding that
even my neighborhood the other day it
was like two in the morning
um we're watching a Muslim video and
like we I had that like that feeling of
that there was something around that was
not that was not any good nature because
even the dog outside was like crying she
tried to let him in when normally they
they don't shut up you know they're
always barking and they're always making
noise but this time they were they were
scared of of how things were going
outside so I met a man and then the next
day I contacted my neighbor and I asked
him like hey did you hear these strange
sounds yesterday
and he was like like bro you're not
gonna believe me for like around two
three he's like I like I woke up and I
woke up in that state where it's like
you know how you get you fun you wake up
in that state where you can't move be
proud he swear bro he swear he saw some
he saw someone on top of the house like
calling like doing something some weird
some weird stuff but on top of on top of
our house because he lives right next to
me
um
but he has been telling me about that as
well and like I've noticed it like I
don't know why but here in Mexico it's
just like really strong Vibes of that
type of those type of entities trying to
work in and and try to put in their work
for whatever their their their their
agenda is you know but but we got to be
careful because even like even in in
regular
um
regular sites that I just visit for
information there's been a lot of
Paranormal Activity like everywhere like
everywhere in the world right now
there's a lot of things coming out and
that we got to be careful you know we
gotta we gotta see and we gotta
acknowledge that they're that they're
gonna be doing their whatever they're
gonna do but at the end of the day
I I think that they're they just they're
like um getting fed for they're getting
fed from all the the
all the um how do you say it
all that fear that is is around our
society for nowadays you know because
nowadays the society lives in fear
because because they know who who Who's
in charge they know what they're doing
and nobody's doing anything about it so
I think like they're getting they're
they're getting stronger because of all
this you know because of how how Society
is mentally getting put into that the
state of fear that the intent the
economy is gonna the economy is going to
collapse anytime at any moment a nuclear
bomb can go like anything can happen
that can destroy the way of the way that
we're living in but that's putting so
much stress under us that instead of
making us think how we should think in
regards to how we're going to act to any
any type of um
cataclysm uh is putting us into that
fear State you know we're we're we're
letting that that it's like it's a dog
it's like a dog when you get when you
when you get close to a dog a dog will
smell if you're afraid of air if you're
not you know and any animal would will
do that even even horses do that as well
like if they smell that that you are
that you are in control of yourself and
that you're not gonna harm him but if he
starts smelling like that you're afraid
of getting close to the to the horse the
horse is not gonna let himself get get
um
tamed
um but it's it's like though we have to
be aware of these things and we don't
have to let these teams these things
um put in fear in us because at the end
of the day only a lot knows when we're
going to get taken you know and it's
it's up to him the day that we are we
are told we are taking but it's up to us
to to know how we're gonna go that day
if we want to go like cowards or we're
going to go like real Muslims you know
what else have you seen the cartel do
aside from like the eating the whatever
you said that uh that you witnessed what
are some like other crazy things you've
seen
it's like
um
it all has to do with these type of
rituals the sacrifices these these
eating of of Flesh and Blood bro because
before like I wouldn't I would know that
certain people did it but then they have
their own they have their own um white
magic and black magic you know there's
like there's something crazy that the uh
what happened um so this person that
this person that took away these these
people before he ate them because these
people were were
enemies they were gonna kill him and
he's like well if you give me this
information I'll let you guys go I'm
gonna spare your life because it's
Christmas
the guys gave him the information he's
like okay you guys can go take a shower
make sure you shave and drink some Buzz
so they went and took a shower they even
give them new clothes and they put them
into a state where they were drinking
their their um their alcohol and they
were calmed down and the guy this guy
came Bam Bam Bam and they started eating
the the meat they started preparing the
meat but it's crazy how there's there's
some there's some there's some there's
some um acts that they'll put the person
in fear you know they'll they'll they'll
let him uh let go of that the what what
the fear causes in our body you know and
that's how they would it's crazy but
these things are getting so exposed to
us and they're getting so put out there
that that even people are starting to
think like what's going on you know who
is it that we're really who who who is
it that we're really in war with if it's
in between us humans or is it between
another uh something else that is in
there that is trying to make us go
against each other and at the end of the
day is trying to
control everything bro to put in their
their to put in their agenda you know
wow
but but it's like
the hardcore stuff is the same hardcore
stuff like in the west room there's
nothing really different because it's
it's basically the same like there's
these small this these small
um cartel members that will that will um
supposedly make deals with the demo or
make deals with whatever they are they
are um involving themselves in but in a
day it's just like they're they're just
Pawns in a bigger game you know the
people that are in the top are the ones
that we have to worry about because
those people are the ones that are
committing all these actors bro they're
they're the ones that see they are the
ones that have that we have been in war
or since the times of
um salahuddin bro you know you ask
yourself who are the Crusaders where
where did the casino what did the
Crusaders become you know and you know
that that there were practicing of the
occult they practiced that they
practiced their core and that's how they
have maintained power and that's how all
these great families and all these where
we're living in how how these we need we
need to start waking up and seeing this
stuff you know and and starting to
understand that it's it's not a game
it's something real and that they want
to see you they want to see your demise
so essentially essentially it's like the
same it's just normal type of magic you
know like Allah in the Quran writes
about how you know the Angels they
basically revealed magic so that we
could differentiate between what is
Magic and what is not but the people
that use magic they have no share in the
Hereafter we know that but essentially
what you're doing is you're basically
making an offering to these gin to do
favors for you so just like in the west
you're saying the cartel do the same
type of stuff they basically use these
entities to do favors for them but what
type of favors do they get them to do
well they they the favorites that they
get is the control and the power you
know the money the power that the that
they have
um the strange part is that
I started I I heard this someone told me
about this right that one day when they
were at one of these these um these
high-ranking meetings where they had to
do these type of of things that he saw
how one of these one of these um
one of these people they they
they transformed into something like
illicit type of person you know and I
was like what I heard when I heard him
say like a lizard type of person I was
like yo you okay you're not high he's
like nah man I said I swear I saw I saw
his face like mutate and they started
eating this stuff you know
and it's like they're working because
the way that he explained to me the
ritual was is basically how the Satan is
in in
these in the second this High occult
satanists that how they they do their
math they do their their rituals bro and
every every single
um
every single thing that they that that
that has to do with their with their
quote thinks it's what what's given to
them and we know what they have right
now you know we know what what these
what these rich families and and these
people that have that accepted the the
magic that um what they have you know
they have the control of this Dunya you
know they have the control that is doing
it they have the control of what we see
what we eat but that's why we have to
wake up and we have to start thinking of
who is it that we're going to stand with
are we going to stand with the people
that are that are our people or are we
going to stand them for the values that
they represent because at the end of the
day I'm not saying that every person
that's from this from these nations or
from from these from these places are
evil they're not because we were born
into this system you know we were born
into this Society but we have the
ability we have we have the knowledge
that Allah has blessed us with to
actually wake up and to difference
between the truth and what's truth and
what's fake bro no at the end we know
that something that we might feel
comfortable with is going to be we might
we might feel that it's good for us but
it's it's bad you know we wake up and we
need to recognize what what is it what
is it that is beneficial for us and what
is it that's going to be
taking us to that to that to the path
that we don't want to end up you know
with a whole bunch we want to be of the
few that that take that risk and that
have to sacrifice whatever we have to
sacrifice in this Dunya because I'm
pretty sure that whatever is whatever is
here whatever we can obtain here it's
it's not going to be better than what
the ahada has to offer you know I mean
bro I was watching this I was watching
this lecture by uh Chef Muhammad Tim
humble who talks a lot about you know
magic and he's from the UK and what he
was saying in one of these lectures that
I watched a long time ago he was saying
that magic is essentially a universal
language bro so the way the way that the
you know magic in the East magic in the
west the magic that we do in Africa
magic that they do in Mexico with the
Saints and everything it's the same type
of magic bro they all use the same type
of numbers and and the same types of of
spells there's no difference bro people
think it's like magic here is different
than magic there
it's the same bro yeah at the end of the
day it gets good versus evil so we have
to we have to decide where we're gonna
stand you know
and it's it's crazy my brother but may
Allah protect us all and keep us safe
but we do have to recognize what's going
on and we we got to start
like you said
making our making our moves because
I wouldn't like to see you you know my
family
um in in hardship but they've they're so
they're they're so used to being in that
lifestyle and and there you they're so
used to comfort comfort that they're not
gonna let it go you know the people that
aren't they're they're basically going
to say no I just I just can't I can't
live without without
um being in this in in this particular
place or having these particular
commodities
um like it's like um they asked me do
you feel Mexican I don't feel Mexican
anymore you know because that's that's
not that's not who I am anymore because
that's not who I stand for anymore you
know that that part has to that probably
has to has to be dead because
nationalist nationalism and patriotism
bro are going to only lead us to racism
and arrogance and feeling that we're
better because we're we were we were we
were placed in a different part of this
world but at the end of the day we're
all gonna we're over we're gonna we were
all born and we're all gonna die nobody
nobody's gonna sit nobody's gonna
nobody's gonna escape death bro you know
and a lot of people they think
they rather stand for for where they
were born for the pride of of that
nationalism or that patriotism that they
don't forget that we're we're none of
that we're Muslims at the end of the day
you know and and that that I consider
myself as a Muslim I don't consider
myself as Mexican and I will never do
you know if I have to move towards
towards the Middle East or wherever I'm
going to move I'm not gonna move like a
Mexican I'm gonna move like a Muslim
because that's what I am at the end of
the day I'm not I'm not going to move
like a Mexican going towards towards
Africa or towards the Middle East no
because I'm looking for the people that
are are identifying us as what I am and
at the end of the day that's we identify
as Muslims bro there shouldn't be no
nationalism or no patriotism in any of
any of us because I think that that's
that's that that's what causes a lot of
problems between us you know because
you're from over there from over here it
costs a lot of it causes a lot of
division bro
and to to be fighting for something that
has no value I'm not gonna fight for any
for anything that has no value because I
know that my values are in in that I am
a Muslim and that I accepted a different
lifestyle than the lifestyle that I was
living before because if I wanted to
live in that old lifestyle I wouldn't be
a Muslim I wouldn't even call myself
but because I am a Muslim I know that
that none of that has to none of that
has to fall in like none of it has to
hurt me like like if I have to say oh I
have to move out of my country because I
feel I feel Mexican I'm gonna stay here
with my people no that's not it your
people are the ones that do the right do
the right you know your people are the
both ones because you have decided to
become a Muslim because you've decided
to stand for what's right
a lot of people they fall in love with
their countries that they don't want to
leave their they don't want to leave the
Commodities of their countries or or the
the I call them the distractions of
their countries than to actually be than
to actually be where you have to be you
know and I would never like I don't know
why but I've always been like I tell my
I tell my my peers here and I tell my
wife that I've always been a mountain
boy you know I I haven't been a a city
dweller I've always been a mountain boy
and I've always liked uh anything
regarding hunting bro I'm I'm really
into hunting I'm really into fishing
I've always practiced but because I've
always practiced those Sports you know
even before I was a Muslim and we would
go into the river and we were Harpoon
fish we would look for our our food like
like uh like like normal people but I
didn't if I wouldn't if I wouldn't have
come here to Mexico I wouldn't have
learned that because I would have grown
up in the southern state of California
just trying to be a gangbanger you know
I want to be and I wouldn't have learned
real like what a what a real man should
stand for you know so you'll be you'd be
bro you be you'd be eating that in and
out in Chick-fil-A bro let's be honest
what I want is that you want to be close
to the to anything that gets me away
from from the GMOs from anything that's
gonna that's gonna cost me any type of
um
any type of bad habits you know because
then they like you eat this food you eat
the fast food that they give you bro and
sometimes you'll feel like in the
indigestion sometimes your own body like
tells you that you shouldn't be eating
that you know and we keep we we keep
putting in that garbage in our in our
bodies but we have to we have to be
taken care of it
it's gonna
inshallah a lot of people are going to
be waking up and realizing the truth you
know and may Allah just help us because
it's not going to be easy bro it's not
going to be easy
what a wonderful point to end it on bro
unless you know the brothers around me
and I don't know have any more questions
um I wanted to ask you one last note
what is any final takeaway any final
note you want to leave the brothers and
sisters that are watching that really
made it this far really stayed to the
end of the stream tuned in for the
entirety listen to everything that we
have to say and they're kind of waking
up now what is one thing you want to
leave them with
um that they're not alone bro sometimes
we think that we're the only ones seeing
all these things you know we're the only
ones that are noticing all these small
signals of of the end times bro you know
sometimes a lot of people will take us
like if we're crazy like if we don't
like if we're the only ones that are
seeing that you guys are not the only
ones that are seeing that you know and a
lot of Muslims are waking up and
actually
pondering on what we're saying and
what's going on around us and that we we
should be getting prepared actually for
for what's coming and the alhamdulillah
that if if you got to this point and if
you got to this time is it because you
really want to wake up you really want
knowledge you really want to benefit for
yourself you know and I think that there
are people that are actually have the
time to listen because sometimes a lot
of people and I I consider myself
sometimes we get we get offended what
we're hearing and we don't want to hear
it we'll shut off from it you know we'll
be like no I don't want to hear that
but then but then we have to come back
and say we have to acknowledge that we
can't be prideful we can't be like
thinking that we know everything we
don't know everything
and we go back and we hear it and that's
when we actually get benefit from
whatever we're listening to for whatever
we are seeing you know and then that's
that they're on the right path and
inshallah
we'll have a good way out of doing it
because it's a mess bro
I mean let me know
well Zach Ali it was uh it was a
pleasure from hosting you again after
almost two years bro I think it's been
and inshallah this is not your last time
on the stream uh Miller protect your bra
Mela protect your loved ones and and
keep us on the right path bro and keep
us fighting on the right side until the
end bro I mean
I mean
all right and with that being said